l'épidémie d'ebola sévit en afrique de
l'ouest parmi les pays qui sont frappés
on retrouve le serment de certaines des
plus pauvres de la planète la guinée la
sierra leone le liberia il ya une
réalité qui joue malheureusement dans la
propagation de ce virus est avec nous
pour nous en parler ce fils un doigt
notre correspondante pour l'afrique qui
s'apprête à s'envoler on peut le dire
dans les prochaines heures injustement
pour la guinée bonjour un jour j'avais
tout de suite on vous demande et plein
de gens qui vont dire mais vous l'avez
bien dit pourquoi vous partez pour la
guinée dans une zone qui est durement
touchée comme celle là mais parce qu'il
faut y aller un on l'a vu on l'a entendu
beaucoup depuis ces derniers jours ces
dernières semaines on a déjà trop tardé
si on avait agi beaucoup plus tôt on
n'en serait pas rendu là l'épidémie
serait probablement déjà maîtrisé or
d'abord en guinée c'est le grand héros
de cette épidémie c'est là que les
voleurs est apparue en décembre mais ça
a pris trois mois aux autorités de santé
guinéenne et internationale pour
identifier les mollahs on savait pas qu
est-ce qui tu es tous ces gens pendant
trois mois en mars sites identifiés et
dès le début médecins sans frontières a
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
en juin ils ont déclaré que cette
épidémie était hors contrôle qui avait
pu riez puis assez de moyens pour même
espérer la halle endiguée à court terme
ils ont répété l'alertent fin juillet
quand les cas au liberia se sont mis à
exploser silence silence silence
il a fallu que des humanitaires blanc
sont infectés en nous pour qu'enfin la
communauté internationale s'éveille j'ai
parlé des médecins qui étaient là en
guinée en juin juillet qui disait que
même l'onu l'organisation mondiale de la
santé qui elle même s'est mis dans le
train pour essayé d'éveiller les
consciences en nous a tardé à mettre les
moyens qu'ils ont envoyé un médecin
québécois me disais pour reprendre une
année
du hockey ils ont pas envoyé le premier
trio ils ont envoyé le troisième trio de
l'équipe b pour attaquer cette épidémie
est notre silence et notre inaction ont
contribué à l'ampleur que prend
aujourd'hui cette épidémie au nombre de
morts et je pense que plus l'information
est difficile parce que je n'irai pas
que ce sera un terrain extrêmement
difficile je pense que après avoir fait
beaucoup de couvertures dans les zones
difficiles à toutes sortes de raisons on
apprend que plus l'information est
difficile à aller chercher plus l'été
important d'aller la chercher sur le
terrain je vous arrête tout de suite il
va falloir que vous nous disiez commun
vous allez aller la chercher parce que
déjà bon on a vu tout à l'heure d'un avc
dans un avion qui a dit ban dès les
beaux là pour de vue rentrer les gens
avec les tenues les masques et cetera
bon vous partez pas combien j'en loue
des informations oui ce qui circule sur
20 à quel point les mollahs et est une
maladie est un virus contagieux
évidemment cela mais ce n'est pas aussi
contagieux contrairement à ce qu'on peut
penser que l'influenza par exemple que
le h1n1 que la grippe aviaire ou ça ne
sera pas dans l'air ni
le virus ne survit pas dans l'eau non
plus donc pourquoi l'épidémie a pris une
telle ampleur vous le disais au début
c'est que ce sont des pays extrêmement
pauvre la guinée est le neuvième pays le
plus pauvre au monde
donc même quand tout va bien quand il a
pas d'épidémie 406 cas le système de
santé manquent de tout manque de
médecins d'infirmières de médicaments
d'équipements et de produits sanguins
1 le virus de l'ebola est une fièvre
hémorragique les gens ont besoin de ça
pour le combattre et il y en a pas donc
on meurt beaucoup plus rapidement les
taux de décès sont sont affolantes parce
que on n'a pas mis les moyens dès le
début qu'on aurait dû main pour y aller
mais ce qu'on a appris dans notre
formation parce qu'on a suivi des
formations c'est que justement c'est
beaucoup moins contagieux qu'on peut
l'imaginer
parce qu'il faut être en contact direct
avec les liquides corporels d'un patient
malade parce que pour être contagieux
faut être malade si on peut être porteur
mais tant qu'on n'a pas de symptômes
on n'est pas contagieux et on n'a pas
l'intention d'aller dans l'unité lise
d'isolement où sont traités les malades
très contagieux on n'a pas besoin d'y
aller on peut faire l'histoire autrement
eh oui on va aller la chercher en se
protégeant comme il se doit
adéquatement comprenant appris à le
faire mais on n'aurait pas
nécessairement besoin de s'exposer à ce
risque extrême qui est celui d'être en
contact avec les mariages et deux
petites choses que j'aimerais voir avec
vous j'ai partagé votre blog j'ai déjà
eu des réactions courageux sophie c'est
entre autres ce qui mentionnait
êtes-vous courageuse vous sentez pas
l'être mais c'est surtout une passion
pour aller dire l'information qui est
difficile à obtenir je pense que
l'afrique
ça fait sept ans que je couvre l'afrique
et c'est souvent des conflits qui
prennent des emplois incroyable avant
qu'on s'y intéresse moi ça fait aussi
longtemps que je tire la sonnette dans
l'âme que je dise depuis que je reçois
l'ailé communiqué de msf en juin écoutez
ça va pas bien il y avait en afrique de
l'ouest va pas bien du tout mais comme
je le disais malheureusement a fallu que
des blancs est donc cette monnaie cela
commence à nous menacer nous que les
gens commencent ici à s'inquiéter de
leur propre santé pour que on s'éveille
à ça
assez pour trouver l'énergie les moyens
d'envoyer les moyens et quand on parle
de moyens pour combattre une épidémie
comme ça il ya bien sûr les moyens
il est médecin l'équipement mais ils
vont aussi les journalistes pour y aller
l'autre petite note vous laisser une
famille derrière vous les petits
arrivent ça brasse quand même évidemment
c'était au début c'est des décisions
extrêmement difficile à prendre et
d'édition familiale je dirais d'abord il
faut que moi je veux y aller mais avant
de dire oui c'est des discussions
familiales qui sont pas facile mais j'ai
la chance d'avoir un conjoint qui est
photographe de presse qu ici à quel
point l'afrique et d'abandonner oublier
parfois juste par les médias par partout
par tout le monde il ya des milliers en
confiance entre afrique qu on oublie une
guerre civile qui est reparti au soudan
du sud on n'en parle pas non plus donc
ils ici à quel point ça me trouble cet
oubli la cette indifférence là et qui
ici que j'en ai fait un peu comme une
mission d'essayer de secouer cette
indifférence le fatalisme l'heure parce
que on a l'impression que parce que
c'est en afrique ça va arriver c'est des
conflits on entend des gens disent
laissons les s'entretuer on l'a on peut
rien faire c'est pas vrai ouais il si
vous êtes évidemment c'est plus
exactement vous souhaite tous merci bon
voyage et bon courage
merci